welcome back we're here with paris
hilton and i'm so excited because i want
to bring out the woman who raised paris
and was has been with her through
obviously her whole life and um someone
i knew as a kid um so i want to hear all
about us as little girls running around
your house please welcome the amazing
icon herself kathy elton
[Applause]
long time
hi everybody
ladies and gentlemen kathy's
is that a lot electronic like edie
parker you know what this is cute
circuit
so cute it's so cool is this not
fabulous and you can
go ahead and
press the button and it can do all
different things so
this uh a little first you you
compliment your wedding
so what is yours here oh oh
that is a rad purse by the way like i'm
like yeah fabulous yeah i really really
like it i like that can you actually
program it to say things you can that's
hot yeah exactly
what were we like when we were kids
running through the house i mean i i
don't know from my perspective i
remember it i remember driving in i
remember my mom classically dropping me
off on kind of cruise in like a friday
and should pick me up like on a monday
yes exactly
that is so classic to my mom
you had a little list i think i still do
you go i'm kind of hungry do you have
any
chocolate chip cookies
what naughty things do you have
exactly no you kids were cute you'd play
downstairs in the big like bonus room
and you'd play ball you'd go outside in
the backyard uh nikki would tag along
nikki would tag along but you both what
you had in common you were both you know
you were tomboys so you get on the bikes
and you know we have that big driveway
and
it was so cute like after we moved from
los angeles here she was the only
thing was when arielle came out the
disney movie she got that red cup the
wig and the costume
she wanted to put it on every day after
school i did go to the market she'd have
this ratty wig i mean we couldn't even
get a brush through it but she loved it
and would wear it every day it had snags
i mean she just really dug this whole
princess and would you let her rock it
absolutely i'm very cool like that i'm
strict in a lot of ways
and what does that mean really strict
because i was a young mother you know i
got married at 19 had her at 20.
so to me she was this china doll
we
end up moving here when she was like
what 16 15 15 16.
and she's doing
wants to be a model
and i'm like
wait what she would meet people in new
york you can easily meet people to give
you your cards so within six months of
being there
i was like
oh no i mean designers sending things i
just wanted to go out and go dancing are
you making me come home at 11 o'clock at
night
i've got everybody in the world calling
me which sounds by the way like every
teenager in america mom i'd rather stay
out late it might grow into something
about
500 cards cards
what 16 year old girl has people handing
guys are trying to hit on me i don't
know what to do business people whatever
okay i was really worried well back in
the 90s kathy and her husband sent paris
to provo canyon school having no idea
what kind of measures they would take
for context let's take a look at this
clip from mrs paris
we're just spending all our time
trying to figure out
where do we should we move to the moon
what do we do
i'm like please kind of just go home
i've already been through so much i
promise i'll never go to a club again
please like i i can't go back to these
places like you've no idea
there was no convincing them no matter
what i said
so i just didn't trust them
it made me not trust anyone not even my
own family
i think that you have taken all your
experiences and become a true warrior
and an advocate because of them
thank you she lights up when she was in
washington she just lit up
every hour and a half meetings meetings
meetings meetings meetings well what do
you think she was on fire because she's
so passionate
[Music]